alright guys I put out champagne because
while the engagement happened back in in
June we have not gotten to celebrate yet
so cheers to you guys but the engagement
now the entire world gets to see yes
I've watched it I was crying it was
sweet it was great to see Jax like
behind the scenes stuff but I didn't
catch that day like I didn't realize
that he was being quiet and like doing
like all being so nervous you know I
didn't catch all that stuff yeah we
gotta lock this out right away because
I'm really want her to enjoy the summer
I am the world's worst secret keeper how
long were you planning in that proposal
and how did that all come together like
how'd you pick the place and all that oh
that's a great great question um well
I've been planning on it for awhile I
thing is I talked it over with my my
jewelry designer Kyle Chan he had to
design the ring it took some time
because it was very you know specific
what she wanted so he had to go find the
dime and find this it was a lot of that
yeah what she wanted she was very like
on the couch she's very well at sea and
such is very like she's like this soon
because he started asking for those
pictures of the Rings okay I didn't
expect it to happen that early I don't
think in the summer of it happened
perfect the way it was but I think I was
thinking it would be like later maybe I
don't think I could have planned a
better day for it just everything it was
perfect the place I chose it was a place
called Neptune's not the reason I chose
that place is because when my father
came in to visit it was his favorite
restaurant and it's a place that we like
to go one of our first dates was there
to like whenever I came to LA where our
first dates with us there it's like crab
and stuff yeah to watch the separate
pieces we loved it we just can see it's
just kind of a messy Hannah place but
it's fun and it's just something that we
enjoyed together we don't have first
dates in like I said my father when he
did come here
his favorite place so I lost my father
last year so it was important to me to
take her there and you know tell her
that I wanted to spend the rest of my
life at my dad's favorite place yeah it
was very emotional and I didn't really
you'll see it I mean I was so nervous I
I don't think I literally blacked out
and I've never blacked out of my life
literally blacked out for a good five
six seconds okay after you and I was
that nerd yeah after I asked I had to
sit down and I was like I'm gonna ask
you I was just like wow I didn't realize
how much this is a big deal it's a big
deal it's a big deal and there's a lot
of things that were going through my
mind and then all the sudden my mind
just went blank and I was just like she
was so shocked it's so surprised and I
was just like I was so nervous my mouth
was dry I was like I was a mess I was a
mess I tried to hide as best I can
because I knew the cameras around like
it was awesome and it was cute and it
was just it was very me it was very very
me
[Music]